These are people who see themselves as
gods who want to be a world historical
figures there. They're literally do that.
Who, who do you think is doing that well?
Like, like Jeff Bezos. You think he thinks
of himself as a god? Yeah. Really? Yeah.
Really you don't, and now I read those
text messages he sent to that check.
I don't think God would say that God
would say you should be lucky to get this
dick on this space exploration
stuff though. It's like,
you know all that people are obsessed
with the life extinction extinction. Um,
but, but don't you think that this is
a side effect of having $150 billion?
You so much good with that. So bayzos
is pouring $1 billion a year into his,
into his space exploration
project, which is like, I mean,
I'm excited by space too.
I think it'd be cool to go up there,
but there's some pressing problems here,
which we could really benefit. You know,
that money could really benefit
and I agree. But Longterm,
I think the philosophy is that we're
going to have to get off this planet.
If the human race is going to succeed,
but because of not just the threat of
global warming but of Astra steroid packs,
it's an asteroid thing I think.
I mean for me Novas there's a lot of
factors mark on the particular question of
climate.
Um,
there's just no way that the earth is
going to get as inhospitable as Mars is.
So the idea of building a colony there
as a hedge against global warming,
it's just crazy. We could, it is
ridiculous on the positive note,
if we could fix that shit
hole, like imagine what we
could do here. Yeah. Paradise.
Yeah. Well the idea is
terraforming, right?
That they can go there with some kind
of massive machine that's gonna create
oxygen and the environment and yeah.
Well that's a good place to
practice because no one lives there.
So you could do all kinds of goofy shit
and go, well, good news and bad news.
The good news is we figured out a way,
terraform,
the bad news is we already fucked up Mars,
so we're going to try another spot.
We're going to go to, you
know, we're going to move on
to see rhinos. Yeah, yeah.
Well, you know, Venus used to be
actually quite earthlike. Yeah.
And they went through a really
rapid global warming that made it,
now it's like a total hellhole and
that's like the sort of worst case.
Worst case for earth is
the venous scenario. Well,
ultimately the sun's going to burn out,
right.
But that's many millions
of years for sure.
But if we really do look into the future,
something, something has to be done.
You know what I mean? This is the,
on the grandest of grand scales, the,
the concept of a, some sort
of interstellar arcs. I
mean, I believe that I'm,
and I'm, I'm, I'm with it. I just think
the timescale of the threat that we're,
that we need to avert by
space exploration. That's
a timescale of Millennia.
Yes.
We have a lot of new technology develop
over the next thousand years that will
allow us to do it better and more
efficiently. But climate change,
the timescale is like the next 30 years.
Right? So we need to focus on it now.
To give ourselves the
opportunity to do the other show.
Why do you think it's sexier to
go to space? Is that what it is?
Like rockets and I mean, I think
for these dudes. Yeah, yeah.
It's a big metal dick.
You shooting off into the atmosphere.
That's what we're doing
and kind of fuck space.
I actually made that argument about Mars.
Yeah.
It's like they're shaped like dicks.
Yeah. Something to that. Yeah.
Well also this generation of
people really grew up in the,
in the age of like the space race.
I mean it's um,
and the aftermath of landing on
the moon and I think there is,
like Peter Teal talks about this,
there's this kind of unfulfilled
sense of future that we all,
like anybody who grew up in the post
war years in the 67 they were like,
you know,
whatever his famous line were promised
flying cars and all we got was 140
characters or whatever. I think that that
applies to the space exploration stuff.
It's like, well, the government is no
longer doing the really ambitious shit,
but we can do it privately.
On the other hand,
there is a government in the world
that is doing that shit. And China,
they just landed on the
far side of the moon.
They're doing really aggressive space
exploration and I haven't been there in 20
years,
but the people I know who live there say
there was so much faith in the future
there. Um, they just
believe in a very inherent,
deep down way that like the future will
be better and Psi Phi e in an exciting
way. And that's so far from the way
that Americans think about the future.
Is that part of the benefit of
having a dictator run things?
I think it's just like they're on a huge
upswing and so like there's no debate
about how things get
done. Yeah, yeah, totally.
I mean that's what I was saying before.
It's like it,
it gives you some hope for climate.
If like Xi Jinping is just like, okay,
immediately, no more
coal, they'll all stop.
But he's also throwing 2 million Muslims
in concentration camps. Yeah. Um,
this bayzos thing,
I mean,
I'm not criticizing you because I
think it's a very common thought,
but why is it that we look at these
super rich billion billionaire characters
that are on the top of the heap?
Why do we think of them as like having
these tremendous egos and looking like
gods isn't it sort of just does just how
you're always going to look at someone
who lives in of $100 million
house and it's possible.
I think when you look at,
I mean not to get too like armchair
psychologizing about basis,
but when you look at the
physical transformation that
he's put himself through,
when you think about like the life
extinction, what has he done physically?
But he's just like,
I mean if,
if you look at photos of him when
he's like a young man, he's, you know,
just kind of like dweeby right? And now
he's like a, um, an action hero. This is,
he really, yeah. I mean maybe not
like you, but he's like, he's, yeah,
he's pretty as big as Jack. Am I
missing something? Let me show you.
Definitely looks different.
Go pull up,
pull ups and marriages of Jeff
Bezos jacked. I didn't know,
but he got a trainer. I mean,
no, I'm not blaming him,
but that's only one part of
it. I would say I'm bigger
than that is, you know, the,
I had just had thin skins. I'm the
worlds. Okay. Let me say zoom in.
I guess he's got some arms there
is. Oh Wow. That's a big difference.
Yeah. But he's also got a vest on.
I guess his arms do look pretty big.
Yeah. I mean in most ways
I'm not a business hater.
I think Amazon has been actually really
pretty great. I'm a fan. Yeah. I like,
well listen to the guy talk and I loved
his letter to the national enquirer.
There he is right there.
Yeah.
So he looks fit in front of the King
Kong rampage movie. Is that him? Yeah.
Yeah, he looks pretty good. Um, okay.
I guess physical transformation, but
that's, yeah. Probably life extinction,
like uploading your brain to the computer.
There's so many busy into that shit. I,
he is actually, I think not as
into it to some other people.